hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute ist valentinstag tag der liebe die
jubi park der geliebten und tag der
liebenden und ich habe heute ein sehr
einfaches und schnelles rezept für euch
falls ihr zum beispiel heute aufgewacht
zeit und den kalender geschaut und
gedacht nach menschheit ist valentinstag
und habe kein geschenk und nicht so weit
den liebsten oder meine liebste könnte
einfach diese nutella herzchen machen
und zwar ist es ein ganz normaler
hefeteig
und da wird dann später mit nutella
bestrichen und dann zu herzen geformt
richtig schön morath will und das habe
ich heute für dich gebacken super klasse
und wasserstoff
was ich will ist es ja was auf jetzt ein
geschenk nicht dann muss ich dann muss
es ja schon steigern dann kriegst du es
ja gar nichts gar nichts
das macht aber nichts denn wir lieben
uns jeden tag
ja ja ich würde sagen wir starten jetzt
direkt und ich zeige euch constrictor
taten
ich stelle jetzt kurz den hefeteig her
und zwar wieder da so ein grundrezept
dann habe ich auch schon bei meinem
allerersten video ministern lostopf und
den habe ich jetzt auch schon öfter
benutzt und es gibt zwar auch andere
hilfe tage mit quark und sahne zum
beispiel aber hier nehme ich einfach
dieses basis standard rezept und zeigt
euch eben die zutaten für den hefeteig
brauche ich einen würfel hefe 80 gramm
zucker 2 esslöffel warmes wasser einen
teelöffel salz etwa 200 milliliter bad
warme mädels ich habe hier 500 gramm
mehl 1 1 etwas von den extra könnt ihr
gerne dazugeben und 80 gramm weiche
butter und es geht jetzt auch ganz
schnell
ich gebe es die hilfe direkt in eine
schüssel da kommt das warme wasser mit
rein und der zucker
und dann höre ich das einmal kurz durch
damit sich die hefe schön auflösen kann
dann gebe ich jetzt dass ein mit rein
und auch die mädels dass vanille extrakt
es gebe ich jetzt mit reingepasst man
könnte aber auch zum beispiel bisschen
zitronenaroma eingehen als
zitronenschale ableiten bioton natürlich
erstmal noch nicht komplett alles je
nachdem wie groß es eben ist kann es
halt immer sein dass sie etwas mehr
mähen oder etwas weniger braucht also
ich ihnen immer so etwa 500 gramm aber
gebt ihnen nun nicht komplett alles
können was ich es erstmal gut
durchkneten
jetzt gebe ich noch so viel milch und
rein damit ein schöner geschmeidiger
teig entsteht
es gebe es bei mir noch ein bisschen
mehr dazu
deswegen halte ich eigentlich immer so
eine schüssel voll mehl doch bereit
und jetzt wieder teig etwa fünf minuten
geklettert wie es sich schön vom
schüssel rand löst und dann ist er
gleich so weit
ich nehme ich den teig raus da ist es
schön geschmeidig und geben hier auf
einer bemehlten arbeitsfläche formen zu
einer kugel zusammen und dann kann ich
dir nämlich nochmal aufgehen lassen das
jetzt einmal von außen nach innen
vorbild dann haben wir gar nicht nur
schöne kugel einfach das mehl von hier
gibt es in die schüssel rein und
bestreut noch mal die kugel damit jetzt
lasse ich den teig so etwa eine halbe
stunde bis stunde aufgehen wieso sich
verdoppelt hat das könnt ihr entweder
bei zimmertemperatur machen oder im
backofen seit vor bald 30 grad aber
nicht heißt denn ansonsten geht diese
kaputt ist
der hefeteig ist aufgegangen und ich
brauche jetzt außer diesen betrag noch
etwas heller
also das sind eigentlich die einzigen
zutaten wie ihr braucht ihr könnt
natürlich diese herzlichen jetzt gleich
auch etwas anderen film
ihr könnt ja auch herzhaft zubereiten
mit einem herzhaften teig also mit einem
salzigen hefeteig und dann zum beispiel
pesto einführung grünes rotes festung
egal wie oder eine leckere frisch
käsecreme so wie zum beispiel ich glaube
einzig der morast aber mehr drüber
gefreut aber ehrlich gesagt schon jetzt
aber ich möchte jetzt gerne teller haben
halbig den teig erst mal ich arbeite
jetzt erstmal nur mit der hälfte geht es
nämlich einfacher und die andere hälfte
lasse ich einfach hier kurz legen auf
etwas nähen und das rolle ich jetzt
schön zu einem rechteck aus
das rechteck gesetzt etwa 20 cm breit
und 40 cm lang also sollte er langsam
als breit und jetzt streiche ich da
nutella drauf falls sie eine andere süße
variante machen wollt um kein nutella
mit könnt ihr zum beispiel auch butter
drauf streiche und zimt zucker
druckstellen oder sogar meine ausbildung
nehmen vom löschzug das geht auch alles
und jetzt wird die schnecke aufgeholt
außerdem ist es von beiden seiten rollen
und zwar so einerseits ein herz werden
deswegen soll ich das jetzt nicht auf
wie bei den lostopf zum beispiel oder
bei zimtschnecken sondern rolle von
beiden seiten bis zur mitte das ist eben
ungefähr gleich ist ihr könnt euch
vorher zum beispiel auch die mitte so
wissel markieren mit einem messer oder
mit der palette
er möchte könnte jetzt noch
bananenscheiben mit reinlegen
so dass sich in der mitte treffen das
ist ihr küsschen verlieren damit jetzt
wird's raum und hilfsprogramm
ordentliches verzückt und wenn ihr die
herzchen größer machen wollt könnt ihr
natürlich auch den ganzen tag benutzen
aber ich möchte es lieber kleine feine
herzchen dann setze ich das auch ein
schneidebrett und jetzt schneide ich da
die stücke ab und zwar so etwa zwei
zentimeter breit
und diese schnecken die nehmt ihr jetzt
und zwar sieht es jetzt nicht so ganz
aus wie ein herz deswegen muss hat es da
unten noch schön formen
dann aufs blech 6
die herzen kommen jetzt in den kalten
backofen den stelle ich dann auf 180
grad und dann brauchen sie so etwa 20
minuten in den kalten backofen deswegen
weil sie jetzt einfach noch mal mit
backofen zusammen aufgehen meine
herzchen sind jetzt gepackt und ich
werde sie jetzt schön anrichten und zwar
habe ich jetzt hier so einen schönen und
länglichen teller
ich möchte meinen teller ja nicht lange
ist es nicht ein thema das immer so
gemeinsam mit widgets dass das kleinste
verschrumpelte das ist jetzt mit dem ruf
hat und wer möchte kann dies zum
beispiel noch business süßen schnee
drüberstreuen so und während ich noch
den schönen teller anrichten darfst du
schon mal ein kleines herz probieren ja
ja also ich finde sie auch vor allem
super hübsch und auch sehr einfach und
wie gesagt könnt ihr die natürlich auch
variieren
ihr könnt da jede andere kühlung rein
machen können so süß oder herzhaft
machen im prinzip geht es hier in dem
video geht eigentlich nur um die form
und ja schnitt noch vor allem sind die
schnell gemacht das heißt wenn ihr heute
am wald dienstag noch nichts bei euren
liebsten oder eure liebste oder führer
eltern oder geschwister oder freunde
habt könnt ihr noch kurz vorbereiten
falls sie alle zutaten zu hause habt und
ich denke dass es auch eine einfach so
eine richtig tolle überraschung
also ich glaube da stehen wir nichts
mehr zu sagen oder
ich kann niemals habe ich nur noch die
überreste seines herzens haben ja ich
mache dir nochmal ein skript number four
1 weil du nichts schönes gesagt nicht
einmal ein kleines herz und danke
schmidt ist echt toll gemacht weil ich
so viel romantik drin habilis mal
angriffs der bachelor als die tür
reinkommen in einem rad weiter gibt es
keine rose für dich heute gibt es einen
her
mit meint er also wenn ihr das rezept
nach machen wollen dann schaut einfach
auf sallys blog.de das stets noch mal
ganz genau und ich freue mich wenn ich
wenn ihr das nach macht und mir ein foto
auf facebook oder instagram sendet und
uns dabei markiert der murat und zell
ist rockmelt also bis zum nächsten mal
ich schenke jetzt aber nichts ich kauf
mir alles sei